Hey Thoughty2 here.
Nestled high up in the peaks of the Himalayan
mountain range, in Northern India, just on
the border of Tibet, lies a mysterious lake
called Roopkund.
Few have traveled to this remote body of water,
5,000 metres above sea level.
But a deadly surprise awaits those who do
embark upon the long trek to visit this terrible
tarn.
Bones, lots and lots of bones.
Most of the year the lake is frozen over but
for one effervescent month each year the ice
melts, revealing the perilous scene at the
bottom of the murky water, for the lakebed
is littered with hundreds of skeletal human
remains.
Human bones can also be found scattered around
the lake’s perimeter in alarming quantities.
It has been estimated that there are skeletons
in and around Roopkund lake, of over 300 people.
The skeletons were first discovered in the
19th century and they remained a morbid curiosity
for hundreds of years.
But very few knew of their existence until
they were rediscovered during World War II,
in 1942.
An investigation began, to discover where
the 300 people who perished at this remote
mountain lake came from, and how they died.
The first and most obvious suspicion was that
they were the bodies of Japanese soldiers
who were trying to sneak their way through
India, earlier on during the war, sneaky Japanese.
And they died due to exposure to cold weather.
But after further inspection it was deduced
that the skeletons were far too old to be
from the war.
Disturbingly these skeletons weren’t just
bones, due to the dry and extremely cold air
they had been preserved for an astonishingly
long time.
Upon the skeletons investigators found bits
of flesh, nails and hair.
And like a scene from Lost, they also found
ancient wooden artifacts, leather shoes, iron
spearheads, wooden staves and jewelry and
an omnipotent man called Jacob, okay maybe
not that last bit.
So surely these remains can’t be more than
a few decades old, otherwise the flesh would
have decayed long ago.
Now this is where things get weird, okay things
are already pretty weird, but this next discovery
will blow your mind.
Samples of the skeletons and surrounding artifacts
were taken to Oxford University where they
conducted radiocarbon dating to uncover their
age.
The remains dated back to 850 AD.
And they still had bits of flesh attached!
How come I have to chuck out food that starts
to look dodgy if it’s been in my freezer
for a couple of months, yet mother nature
can preserve parts of human bodies for almost
1,200 years?
No evidence of a settlement has ever been
found near the bodies, so it’s assumed all
300 people were travelling at the time of
their demise.
So the obvious question is, what killed them
all?
Starvation, gangrene, a landslide, were they
attacked by marauders?
Was it aliens perhaps?
But before you’re so quick to blame aliens,
because I know you’re just dying to, perhaps
local legend can shed some light onto this.
According to the legends, the once king of
Kannauj was traveling with his pregnant wife
on a pilgrimage, as part of the Nanda Devi
Raj Jat, which is a large pilgrimage that
takes place in these parts of India, every
12 years.
Being wealthy, the king and his wife were
traveling with around 300 servants, among
them were his personal dance troupe.
Because if you were traveling on a long pilgrimage
across the Himalayas you would obviously take
a dance troupe, in case you get bored or something,
and if you get stranded then you can always
eat them.
However, the legend also tells of a freak
hailstorm around that time, when enormous
balls of ice pelted down from the sky, one
hit from such a mighty hailstone could quite
easily cause death.
It could certainly wipe out a group of 300
pilgrims high up in the mountains, especially
when you consider that the lake is in a large
open expanse with little to no shelter nearby.
In 2013 researchers examined the bodies in
more detail and discovered that every person
was killed by blows with a blunt object, to
the head, neck and shoulder region.
The large, circular holes in the skeleton’s
skulls seems to suggest that the sudden and
violent hailstorm legend could have been responsible
for the mysterious 9th century human remains.
However, this theory is the best we have so
far, but the mystery has certainly not been
proven and there are many people who say the
hailstorm idea is completely wrong.
The bodies all had damage to their heads and
shoulders but absolutely no damage below the
shoulders.
Hailstones aren’t that selective, surely
if 300 people were killed by large balls of
ice, they would have sustained injuries all
over their bodies, some people would get knocked
over and pelted with hail on their torso and
legs.
And what about their arms?
People most certainly would have put their
arms above their heads in an attempt to protect
themselves.
Yet no skeletons were found with injuries
to their arms.
Hmm, suspicious.
So then, until we come up with another, more
plausible solution to explain this most mysterious
conundrum, it will remain a mystery.
I know, it was aliens, yep, definitely aliens.
Thanks for watching.